hallo mein name ist meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einer
neuen episode whatsapp tales mit luca
das bin ich
und wir jetzt mal so richtig unsere
gehirnzellen habe unser wlan heute in
verbindung nicht möglich umbenannt meine
ganze familie dreht gerade durch du
kommst safe in die hölle und ich kann
direkt mit genen ich habe in meiner
wohnung in köln damals mein wlan
passwort auf es gibt kein passwort
genannt und immer wenn freunde ins wlan
wollten und gefragt haben hey was das
passwort habe ich nur gesagt es gibt
kein passwort
er fragte ein elternteil
das kind sag mal wo ist denn ein zeugnis
eigentlich und nach einer stunde
schreibt die personen einfach noch mal
so nah bei timo warum denn bei timo er
wollte seine eltern erschrecken ergänzt
sich der klasse
herr papa sag mal bin ich eigentlich das
kind von dir oder von mama ja stell dir
das mal an hand eines getränkeautomaten
fotos text ein euro hinein und eine
flasche kommt raus gehört die flasche
dann dem automaten oder dir danke papa
so
einmal war es richtig geile erklärung
und auch indes an den sohn weil er
angeblich eine flasche ist mama was
haben oma und opa eigentlich gemacht als
ihnen langweilig war und es noch kein
internet und so gab nach da kannst du ja
mal meine sieben geschwister fragen hey
ja
den witz verstanden dann beschreibt zwar
in die kommentare und lasten abo da
unten like und zeigt das video ihrer
ganzen schule ich bin echt froh dich
meine schwester nennen zu können ich hab
dich lieb ich dich auch fahrspaß stinkst
und du penner schultes mir noch 17 euro
hab dich doch lieb
ja
geht man eigentlich nach hinten
hahahahaha wir waren ja heute bei ikea
und mir war einfach mega langweilig weil
mama und papa hat jahrelang nach einem
sofa gesucht haben dann bin ich einfach
zum bällebad gegangen und habe den
kindern daher zählt dass mich meine
eltern schon vor zwölf jahren abholen
wollten
wenn du das im kleinen luca gesagt hätte
dass ich meine faust genommen
wahrscheinlich gar nichts gemacht weil
ich hatte noch nie muskeln mama was
macht ihr heute abend wir haben eine
familien besprechung um zu überlegen wie
sie in zukunft mit dem schwarzen schaf
der familie umgehen sollen ok warum weiß
ich davon nichts punkt um punkt
bruder
ich bin für dich da
wir haben gerade lehrermangel in der
schule weil zu viele kinder in die
schule gehen und deswegen habe ich mir
überlegt dass ich jetzt einfach mal ein
paar wochen zu hause bleiben um die
lehrer zu entlasten ok sobald du die
zeichensetzung beherrscht können wir uns
da gern darüber unterhalten ja
das
würde ich mir oft auch mal hier in den
kommentaren
ganz kurz übrigens wirklich mein real
tor zu der kommentar sektion aktuell auf
youtube und zwar stehen überall so
komische google codes in den kommentaren
von wegen google das und bekommt zehn
jahre mehr lebenszeit das ist alles scam
und die verarschen euch man kann die
leute nicht blockieren weil die immer
einen neuen weg mit einem neuen code
finden und zwei sonst so klickt da nicht
drauf klickt lieber hier drauf unter dem
video das macht deutlich mehr sinn und
da kriegt ja auch 20 jahre lebenszeit
noch und topcu nächste woche wirst du ja
schon 18 jaha dann kann ich endlich tun
und lassen was ich will naja solange du
unter unserem dach lebte folgst du auch
unsere regeln das ist ein richtiger
ahlmann annette spruch
solang du mein kleiner bruder hat heute
im kindergarten einfach dreck gegessen
der idiot hahahahaha wtf und was habt
ihr denn gemacht
geht es ihm gut jaha die erzieherin war
so voll besorgt dass wir ihn abholt
haben aber wenn man meint sie nur so
nach super brauchen wir kein mittagessen
waren nämlich menschen nicht gesund
ziemlich abstoßen die kannst es nicht
haha was papa hat gerade die zeitung
gelesen und hat air force einfach als
ausgesprochen ha ha ha ha ha ha ha für
euren humor
gerade
dass ich das ja noch das essen von
gestern steht das sieht gar nicht mehr
so appetitlich aus ich bin nicht
eingebildet aber wenn ich morgen
geburtstag habe schenke ich meinen
eltern eine glückwunschkarte will
als zu
ach so ich meinen eltern auch mal geben
warum habt ihr mich bettina genannt papa
nach dem ort wo wir dich gezeugt haben
und meine brüder was soll mit
motorhauben handels und rücksitz otto
seien die fragen sich ob die geschichte
wahr ist
ich muss sie enttäuschen sie liegen
daneben sie ist frei von a-ha weißt du
was ich mir mal aufgefallen ist was denn
als schülerinnen damals bin ich extra
immer so um sechs uhr aufgestanden damit
ich duschen haare war schon mich
schminken kann und jetzt als studentin
regt es mich schon mega aufwendig um 9
uhr aufstehen muss haha und außerdem
frage ich mich dann immer so sachen ob
man beispielsweise trockenshampoo vier
tage hintereinander benutzen kann ha ha
ha seid ihr auch so
also ich
bin auch so tim was war jesus als
student warum schreibst du mir sowas um
2 uhr 40 nachts alter weißt du es denn
keine ahnung student er wohnt mit 30
noch bei seinen eltern hatte lange haare
und wenn er was tat war als ein wunder
geh bitte wieder schlafen das ist ich
glaube jeder hat seine person im
freundeskreis die einfach und normal
krass davon überzeugt ist dass sie
lustig ist es aber einfach nicht ist bei
uns bin ich das
habt ihr euch in der schule so gemeldet
so
oder so ich immer so
apropos schule allerdings meine lieben
freunde king von überleitung des bag in
bern vor an der schule handelt nämlich
auch dieser bortfeld und zwar schreibt
der nachhilfelehrer seinem schüler das
hier auf whatsapp ok probieren wir das
mit der mathe nachhilfe mal anders stell
dir vor du hast vier knöpfe in deiner
hosentasche und zwei fallen die heraus
was hast du dann in deiner hosentasche
ein loch ich gebe es auf
find ich halte das mir sandra einfach
auch so bot es mittlerweile schon ein
schickt habe meiner oma heute das
internet gezeigt und bei google meinte
ich halt dass sie nach allem suchen kann
was sie will also hotels schauspieler
rezepte et cetera und was sucht die
direkt gertrud müller
wer ist das unser nachbar die kann alles
googeln und googelt ihren nachbarn ja
aber so sind ältere menschen oft die
sind mit ganz wenig zufrieden zu stellen
und ich finde das ist eine sache die
sollte auch in unsere gesellschaft
wieder mehr anklang finden einfach mit
den kleinigkeiten
ich weiß so ganz kleine dinge freuen
nicht hier sicher zu weihnachten
wünschen und neues iphone und den
fernseher
von storch
kommen wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
letzten wort fällt fürs heutige video
und zwar habe ich diesen whatsapp fällen
nicht so richtig verstanden
wir hatten so einen ähnlichen feld schon
mal vor einem jahr oder so in der
episode und zwar bekommt eine person die
nachricht geschickt liebst du mich an
der antwortet er antwortet nee
geschrieben aus glas so was hat er
geantwortet wenn jetzt wisst schreibt
mir gern unten in die kommentare und
kohle